we want to talk about no film school
calm in terms of how many page views
does it get each month
what were the page view starting out and
how did you get this tremendous growth
that we've seen sure sure
you know I actually have launched to a
film school as a personal blog in 2005
and that's what that's what actually got
me a job in New York City and I moved up
there and but really the website that we
think of it as today I launched in
January of 2010 and at that point just
because it was a personal blog it was
averaging I think you know thirty nine
views a month or something no one was
reading it so so for all intents and
purposes it started at zero and so now
we're doing two million page views a
month we've been growing fairly
consistently since I launched it and
it's been great I mean when I launched
the site I had no idea whether anyone
was gonna read it you know I only spent
a week designing it because I didn't
want to you know sort of front load all
of work and then find out that you know
I built it but no one came so it's been
great to sort of have the community
there and we're currently completely
redesigning and we'll be relaunching it
soon I hope but yeah so we're doing two
million a month and what was the other
question when you when you started out I
just want to go back to to starting out
that personal blog back in 2005 what was
your desire behind I think that's great
that you had a passion for it and you
you went for it probably never thinking
that it would ever turn into this so you
just wanted something like in your spare
time to kind of you know you passionate
about cameras tell me from 2003 to 2005
I was a video producer in North Carolina
which is where I'm from and I just I
went shot a documentary in the Amazon
jungle
in Ecuador and I could only shoot it
during my vacation that I had accrued so
I went for two weeks and that was really
the breaking point of realizing I can't
be a filmmaker and have a full-time day
job at the same time and I knew that I
didn't want to go to film school
thus purchasing the URL and so me
launching the personal blog was a way of
putting myself out there knowing that I
was recently unemployed of my own
volition and that I was going to be
trying to get myself to New York City
but I didn't know anyone in New York so
how you know how can I reach across
geographic boundaries well the internet
that's the great thing about you know
the world wide web so really it was just
me talking about movies a lot and I
ended up interviewing with a couple with
an indie film company in New York who
didn't hire me and sort of fell faces
the earth but somebody else read what I
was writing about these experiences and
I saw that his signature said senior
producer at MTV so you know that contact
initially was because of my website and
that's really when I you know learned
sort of about the power of the Internet
and that's really what motivated me to
to keep doing what I've been doing and
unfortunately they were hiring graphic
designers at the time and I wasn't a
graphic designer
but I didn't stop me from saying that I
was a graphic designer so you know I was
able to lie my way into a job in New
York based on creating a fake portfolio
and putting on a suit and driving myself
there and taking this interview and then
doing Photoshop training on the train
every day to and from work but that was
kind of you know the impetus behind the
power of the internet and sort of
knowing how it hit home personally was
being able to get myself from an
unemployed kid living in North Carolina
with
parents too you know working as a senior
designer at NTV in the middle of Times
Square because of my website when you
first launched that blog how many hours
a day were you putting into it I'm sure
now it's probably every waking minute
but in terms of back then what were you
putting into it well when I first
launched it in 2010 as the current site
it was it was a full-time job
essentially not not a full-time job
posting content but I wasn't somebody
who knew how to run a website I didn't
know of things about search engines and
you know inbound traffic and marketing
and advertisements and monetization and
all the sort of things that you would
see on a website if you went to a
website and there was a masthead and it
was editor managing editor bizdev you
know outreach publicity all of those
things I had to learn about and so when
I launched the site I told myself I'm
gonna post one thing a day that way
people will know that there's something
new here every day so they can come back
and it's not gonna be something where I
post one thing and there's nothing for
three months but during that first year
of growing the website from nothing it
was just research you know most of my
time was spent learning about these
things and and they're great things to
know about now but I essentially had to
put my film career on hold for a year
while I learned about all these other
aspects of running a website and then
once I've been running it for a year and
we reached a certain traffic level
that's when I was able to sort of cut
down in the research just run the
website and work on my screenplay at the
same time what do you think has been the
most important thing in getting that
traffic or is probably a combination of
many things can you share some tips for
other people that want to start their
own site whatever it is it's about food
trucks or whatever it is sewing I think
you know with web sites people there are
so many websites out there that the
challenge of launching website is if
someone comes and they read something at
your site or they watch a video at your
site and they never come back because
there's just so many out there so the
challenge is how do you keep people
coming back
to your site and of course there are the
usual approaches of just having better
content you know and trying to do a
better job and making sure that your
content is better written than other
people's but to me the thing that we
ended up being successful with was when
I wrote this DSLR cinematography guide
which was or still is because we're a
little out of date now we need to update
it and we're gonna do that when we you
know have some yeah but so that's you
know one hundred and something pages and
we gave it away for free in exchange for
an email address and anyone can sign up
for it and then unsubscribe if they
don't want to get our updates but that
was the thing that really I think kept
us on people's minds and so you came and
you got this guide and then you started
getting emails and coming back to our
site so that way we were able to grow
our community from you know week to week
and month month as opposed to just sort
of having this revolving door of people
coming and then forgetting about the
site if someone does want to start their
own site from scratch and just kind of
dip their toe in the water what are some
what's what's sort of the quick and
dirty what are some of the tips you know
get the domain name would you advise
WordPress a Wix site like what what are
some one just two quick quick things you
can advise us on one that's a good
question you know I think it for example
will WordPress is great I've built a lot
of sites on it
you know can't beat the price it's free
and you can customize it every which way
but I think every it's like cameras
every you know film project it requires
a different or a different camera would
be best for different you know kinds of
film projects and websites are the same
if we're actually going to be migrating
off of WordPress for our next version
not because WordPress is bad but just
you know what you're trying to do has a
different tool so something like Wix or
you know the hands there's a lot of
portfolio sites which is in there now
part of Adobe's Creative Cloud if you're
using their software you know how this
portfolio website software included you
know Vimeo Pro is also something where
you can sort of host your own business
and you know most your video and all
those sorts of things so I think it
depends on whether you're primarily
trafficking video or whether you're a
news site whether you're a community a
lot of people use like vbulletin for
forums it's just sort of knowing what
you're doing right now and where you
want to take it and then thinking about
which tools we're going to get you there
I think
you